maël de calan il va peser combien est-ce
que ça va être un dimension laurent
wauquiez va devoir tenir compte ça doit
dépendre du score de me répéter toutes
les semaines mais le rassemblement des
personnes il se fera pas ce qu'il se
fait toujours si ça marche du côté de
wauquiez mails de calan viendra puis
valérie pécresse si ça marche finira par
venir mais vous avez bertrand un beau
jour se dira s'il n'a pas entre temps
été nommé prémunissent par macro après
tout pourquoi pas donc la grille de
calandre alors c'est moi je pense que là
encore c'est vraiment pas le sujet il
faut éviter d'injurier les gens de les
avoir tous contre soi mais c'est pas la
bataille la bataille très difficile pour
vos pieds c'est de réconcilier sont ces
électorats de effectivement pas ne fait
pas des patrons hollandais qui le soir
après ça on verra c'est de ne pas faire
fuir l'électorat bourgeois modéré prenne
pas ses jambes à son cou faut pour
l'instant il est quand même très chez
makro mais c'est aussi et je dirais
d'abord de faire revenir lectorat
populaire droite qui est -ce qui est
partie sous marine le pen donc et puis
ensuite de trouver le ciment qui va
faire tenir tout ça ensemble
c'est extrêmement difficile mais je
pense que le problème même si mal de
cadres a plein de qualités c'est pas mal
de câlins ou pierre ou paul ou jacques
où nous l'aurions fait